oh my god i don't know oh they shooting
oh my god
oh my god they shooting
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i can't believe this oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
you telling me to calm down i just
watched somebody
body just fly out the window and they
drive in the hallway
oh my god
and they wouldn't stop with the dude
hanging out the front windshield
oh my god lord jesus look everybody
oh god
i don't know what's going on but we was
on the freeway the police chasing
somebody
they threw the thing out for their tires
to go on flat the tire went on flat
a body hanging out the window and the
person driving still
driving with the passenger hanging out
the front windshield
and we didn't win so far down now they
got the car to stop and they just
started shooting oh my god
man oh my god highway patrol was chasing
this car
and then they put the spikes out and it
wrecked and the boy one of the boys was
hanging out the front windshield
we had a standstill now we right here on
it ate a recording
and then they just shot them shot them
dead and then
they were right here on spring mountain
on the freeway on the 95
and uh hey and i watched the body come
out the window because i'm walking
watch
the passenger legs was out the
windshield the windshield all blown
out and then so they keep chasing him
and trying to push him to the side
and they surrounded him right here on
spring mountain on the freeway
they get out the car start shooting so
he must have pulled a gun or something
this is sure this is crazy man this
is crazy we can't even move but this and
she crying i'm thought
what
this was like in a movie the boy
and the person driving trying to drive
with the tires on flat and trying to
pull his window
trying to still pull him in the inside
of the car man
and then they just pulled their guns man
and got the shooting i don't know if
they pulled the gun out or what
oh my god whatever video you got
we got it but we should have been
recording oh my god
where's you trying to go just stop until
they tell us we can go
just stop all right son
oh my god no
we right in front of the shooting and it
stopped and all the cars are stopped
right here and we can't even move right
now
i don't know what happened y'all but
this is crazy
oh okay
i don't know what happened we was
driving on the freeway and they got like
all the intersections blocked off
so milton was like turn around and look
behind us so when i turned around the
police threw out spikes
and the car ran through the spikes and
the tires went on flat
the person on the passenger side flew
out the front window the person driving
still driving
with the passenger legs hanging out the
window soon as the police get ready to
get him to stop
they just start shooting
he must have pulled the gun oh my god
it's crazy
and i'm telling milton it's feet hanging
out the window while this person is
still trying to drive the front
windshield just
broke out the tires on flat and they
still trying to drive with the passenger
feet hanging out
whole body hanging out the window
look at the chopper man i'm gonna try to
blow it up right here
right here on it right on it but i don't
know if i got them live when they
started shooting or whatever
the helicopter just went the helicopter
has landed right here on the freeway
[Music]
they all got the shoe man i mean
everybody every police got out that car
with shoes
are you hurt 10 to 15 feet away
10 feet away it's crazy man
i just heard the call it's crazy
remember aydah gonna send you the video
soon as we uh
done recording all right
all right man everybody look metro
now i told you movies coming i was like
they got the exit blocked
it's crazy must have pulled the gun
because he didn't want to get caught who
whatever going on
every police got out they car was
shooting but that
was driving them about his friend
hanging out the window
he was trying to pull him in while he
was driving still yeah
look everybody getting out their cars
and everything
i'm not going up there
yeah everybody all out their cars
on the freeway
look they got the body going to the car
to the uh helicopter and i mean
he was hanging out the window while he
was driving
they putting the body in the helicopter
right now
[Music]
[Music]
whoever was driving was trying to pull
the body still in the car yeah
she said from lake me yeah
barry say you better not take you down
there terry neal
look they got one of the bodies in the
car in the uh helicopter
i don't know what color they was all i
seen was legs hanging out the window
yeah i'm sure you did
[Music]
you